Tình hai khi mà kém tập bài toán này thì kém biết được đây được tập sĩnh màm xuống này này era thì tức là kém cần phải có được điều kiện nằm mới đi phương còn mày sống mới ấy
Cậm mới bệnh mơ còn bệnh
Bởi vì rất mọi ý thuê rồi
Tình hai đập tức kém thấy là là yếu phải tăng tức bài hàng kè
Cái này phải tăng tức bài đó chưa chắc
Dạ vì mơ có thì bằng không
Nên con rất là kém niên sẽ trởi mùn
Điếu mà mà mà mà không ý
thì kể điều kiện một của chúng ta sẽ tương đông điều gì
Tương đông phải bệnh lớn không
Tương đông phải mọi thứ này rồi
Điều này đã điếu phải mạnh luôn
Nó ngày ai mới của nó thúc sẽ mơ vào thúc thúc thúc thúc thúc thúc thúc thúc thúc
Còn trong trận mơ mà khá khó không ý